de nos jours l'une des industries qui
investit le plus dans l'intelligence
artificielle et l'industrie des
assurances
le principe d assurance et de faire
payer régulièrement des sommes modestes
pour couvrir des coûts futurs
potentiellement très importants quoique
peu probable d'une certaine manière il
s'agit de diluer les risques individuels
autrement dit en termes bayésiens parmi
les futurs envisageable une grande
majorité de ces futurs sont sans coup
majeur
cependant sans couverture par un
assureur il existe une petite fraction
de futurs qui sont associés à un coût
énorme suite par exemple à un accident
choisir une couverture revient alors à
lisser les futurs possibles en payant
une somme modeste dans tous les cas y
compris ceux où aucun accident n'a lieu
l'assurance offre alors le service de
centraliser et gérer les risques de
différents clients et grâce à la loi des
grands nombres
elle peut ainsi garantir que les prix
des assurances payé par le plus grand
nombre
suffiront à aider la minorité qui en
aura besoin
et bien entendu ceci requiert des coûts
de gestion et les assurances prennent
donc le soin de récupérer dans leur
poche une fraction de l'argent ainsi
transférés alors on peut critiquer ou
non le fait que les assurances qui
effectue ce travail soit des entreprises
privées motivée par la maximisation des
profits dans un contexte compétitif mais
il n'en reste pas moins remarquable que
ce faisant l'assurance résout presque
par accident un problème de société à
savoir redistribuer les richesses de
ceux qui ont eu la chance de ne pas
avoir eu d'accident au cours de leur vie
le théoricien des jeux en moi ne peut
que s'émerveiller devant ce bel
alignement des incitatifs
mais il se doit aussi de remarquer qu'il
est en fait loin d'être parfait cet
alignement
surtout que l'avènement du big data et
désire risque de changer la donne
en effet le job d'un assureur c'est
avant tout de déterminer les prix des
assurances de différents risques et bien
entendu plus le risque est probable et
coûteux s'il advient plus le prix de sa
couverture sera important le travail de
l'assureur est donc avant tout un
travail de prédiction et pour ce faire
l'assureur va vouloir s'informer des
risques potentiels en collectant et en
analysant toutes sortes de données avec
ou sans dire sauf qu'avec le big data
les assureurs ont désormais accès à
toutes sortes de données individualisé
ils peuvent donc ajuster les coûts
probables de l'assurance d'un individu
en fonction des données spécifiques à
l'individu
big man c'est un individu fait
régulièrement du sport manche de façon
saine et n'a aucun risque génétique
alors l'assureur sera amené à diminuer
la probabilité que cet individu
nécessite une hospitalisation majeur le
coût de la couverture de cet individu
diminuera et l'assureur pourra donc
également diminuer le prix de son
assurance sauf que bien sûr al'inverse
s'il assure rares apprend qu'un individu
a effectué un séquençage de son génome
et que ce séquençage suggère que
l'individu un risque important de
développer un cancer alors l'assureur
augmentera la probabilité que le coup
d'assurer cet individu sera important et
du coup il semblera justifié pour
l'assureur d'augmenter également le prix
de l'assurance alors ce qui m'a motivé à
faire cette vidéo c'est l'impression
notamment donné par ces deux vidéos que
l'on se dirigeait vers une
ultrapersonnalisation des assurances via
le big data
en tout cas ça semble vraiment être le
cas aux états unis et en suisse mais je
suis ensuite tombé sur ce rapport de
l'institut national de la consommation
qui suggère que l'union européenne s'est
mise à réguler la personnalisation des
assurances et qui plus est je ne suis
pas juriste et je suis très ignorants de
la loi donc je sais vraiment pas en fait
ce qu'il en est légalement
quoi qu'il en soit je vous propose
d'étudier les conséquences d'un marché
des assurances sans régulation en
présence de big data et d'intelligence
artificielle et on peut souligner trois
problèmes posés par les nouvelles
technologies et l'ultra personnalisation
des assurances le premier c'est que dès
lors on sort du schéma classique où tous
les individus étaient logés à la même
enseigne et où les malheurs des uns
étaient compensées par le prix des
assurances des autres en personnalisant
les prix les assurances on obtient alors
un système où chacun paie quelque chose
de bien plus proche de ses coûts à venir
l'assurance perd alors son rôle social
de redistribution des richesses des
individus les plus chanceux le second
problème c'est que les individus ont
désormais intérêt à cacher les données
les concernant
pour éviter une augmentation des prix de
leurs assurances typiquement ils ont
tout intérêt à garder secret le
séquençage de leur génome voir à ne pas
chercher à séquencer le génome
or on peut y voir un échec de santé
publique
en effet médicaments pour soigner aussi
bien que possible les patients de telles
données peuvent être cruciales
elle pourrait améliorer le diagnostic et
permettre des prescriptions plus adéquat
c'est d'ailleurs en cela que la relation
entre un patient et un médecin doit être
aussi protégé que possible c'est sur une
telle relation de confiance que repose
la volonté
d'un patient à partager toutes ces
données personnelles aux médecins et la
capacité du médecin a alors choisir des
traitements adéquats
le troisième problème ce sont les
incentives des assureurs qui eux vont
avoir tout intérêt à violer la vie
privée des personnes qu'ils assurent
surtout dans un cadre compétitif
les assureurs doivent chercher à
diminuer autant que possible le prix de
leur assurance ce qui peut se faire en
les personnalisant à l'aide de données
individuelles et c'est pour ça que les
données médicales balle si cher
aujourd'hui on estime même que ces
données médicales valent encore plus que
les données financières
or bien entendu la protection des
données privées est un problème qui
transforme de l'augmentation des prix
des assurances avoir vos données privées
exposé peut donner lieu à toutes sortes
de stigmatisation de cheminot de bowling
sur internet cela peut conduire à des
problèmes d'usurpation ou à des refus de
prêts bancaires ce qui peut ensuite
avoir des conséquences sur votre
capacité à louer un appartement ou à
trouver un travail
la violation des données privées peut
avoir des conséquences majeures sur
votre vie d'où l'importance de la
gestion adéquats des données privées et
de réglementation comme hergé [ __ ] cette
loi de l'union européenne qui a causé
une avalanche de messages d'entreprise
du web dans votre boîte email
il ya quelques mois gérer adéquatement
vos données privées et faire en sorte
que vos données privées soient gérées
convenablement par un tiers de confiance
c'est une question de sécurité
internationales malheureusement il
s'agit aussi et surtout d'un problème
techniquement très difficile et complexe
certes quelques notions académique ont
été introduites comme la confidentialité
différentiel donc je parle dans le
chapitre 8 de mon livre mais c'est ne
sont pas toujours bien comprise par les
juristes et les ingénieurs et elle
semble beaucoup trop contraignante pour
les entreprises à bien y réfléchir il
serait malencontreux d'imposer aux
entreprises d'obéir à des règles alors
que les chercheurs sont eux mêmes
incapables de produire des algorithmes
qui parviennent à obéir à ces règles en
fait quand il s'agit de protection des
données privées il est bon de d'abord
bien comprendre ce qui est
technologiquement possible et ce qui ne
l'est pas et d'estimer les coûts
qu'engendrerait telle ou telle
réglementation malheureusement
aujourd'hui même au niveau académique
aucun cadre généralement applicable ne
semble émerger ensemble contraint de
raisonner au cas par cas ce qui
nécessite beaucoup de recherches est
beaucoup d'exploration et de fausses
pistes
bref explorer le domaine des possibles
en termes de protection des données
requiert beaucoup de temps d'énergie
de financement bon ceci dit à la
recherche avance et elle a déjà beaucoup
avancé mais même lorsque certains
problèmes sont résolus comme dans le cas
du sondage la platière pour garantir la
confidentialité différentiel sans coup
majeur pour l'analyste des données ils
demeurent souvent compliqué de passer
des principes théoriques aux
applications pratiques entre autres
beaucoup de pédagogie semble absolument
indispensable pour mieux aiguiller les
ingénieurs et les aider à implémenter
ces idées or de nos jours il y a très
peu d'investissements dans la
vulgarisation des grands principes
algorithmique
bref la protection des données privées
est un vaste chantier et il me semble
qu'il ya un manque cruel d'expertisé de
transparence à tous les niveaux ceci
étant dit même si ce problème était
mieux résolus la personnalisation des
prix des assurances notamment via dei
exploitant le big data soulève une autre
question de société qui me semble plus
importante encore souvenez vous on a dit
que quand les assurances fixer un même
prix pour tous alors elle permettait par
accident une forme de redistribution des
richesses pour les plus malchanceux mais
si les prix des assurances ont désormais
personnaliser alors cette redistribution
a beaucoup moins lieux et du coup il
faudrait peut-être commencer à penser à
mettre en place un autre système qui
malgré tout vient en aide aux personnes
handicapés et accidentés et en fait ça
ça correspond à une question plus
globale qui et comment identifier les
gens qui ont le plus besoin dead et
déterminés collectivement led qui doit
leur être attribuées et à bien y
réfléchir à ce jeu là plutôt que de
cacher les données privées de tous pour
traiter tout le monde de manière égale
il pourrait être utile d'exposer
partiellement les différences entre
différents individus
ça peut être utile par exemple pour
mieux identifier ceux qui vivent en
excès et puis une fraction trop
importante des ressources comme le
suggère le réveil heures et ce genre
d'exposition partielle des données
privées pourraient également être utiles
pour mieux identifier ceux qui ont le
plus besoin ted ça peut vous paraître
étrange comme idée mais ne pas traiter
les individus de manière égalitaire
c'est déjà ce qui se paie dans le bus
bah oui les bus invite souvent les
passagers à laisser la priorité aux
places assises aux personnes âgées
handicapées et aux femmes enceintes et
ça au final c'est ni plus ni moins
identifié des particularités
individuelles voire se fonder des
préjugés sur des individus simplement à
partir de leur apparence physique
afin de mieux les aider autrement dit
les bus nous invite à exploiter les
stéréotypes et à effectuer des jugements
de faciès afin de venir en aide plus
rapidement et plus efficacement aux
personnes les plus démunies et sa part
est au moins partiellement moralement
justifié en tout cas pas entièrement
condamnable d'ailleurs de nombreux
chercheurs proposent d'en faire de même
pour la lutte contre la pauvreté
il propose ainsi d'exploiter l'image
satellite habitations de millions voire
de milliards d'individus sur terre afin
d'identifier les zones d'extrême
pauvreté pour mieux leur venir en aide
leur solution consiste donc à violer
partiellement la vie privée de ces
individus pour mieux les aider
ni à devra-t-elle en faire de même à
quel point devrait-elle violer nos vies
privées
sachant que cela peut grandement aider à
aider plus efficacement et plus
rapidement les personnes qui en ont plus
besoin et surtout y aurait-il un système
efficace qui pourrait être mise en place
pour prélever le surplus ce superflu des
plus fortunés afin de venir en aide à
ceux qui en ont absolument besoin
ce sont là des questions extrêmement
difficile notamment car cela mail une
dimension morale sur laquelle on est
très oligan et une dimension
technologique sur laquelle on est très
ignorants on est là les deux pieds dans
un domaine où nos intuitions sont très
très mauvaise j'aurais donc tendance à
vous encourager à ne pas conclure et au
contraire a cherché à calmer mon mieux
vous informer et peut-être qu'après plus
de réflexion vous conclurez comme moi
que nos intuitions naïve sont souvent
très inadéquat pour appréhender la
complexité de notre monde moderne
l'anr fin on a parlé de racisme et je
vous ai parlé notamment de tête 8,7 il a
inventé par microsoft qui interagissent
est sur twitter et chocat paf fait
remarquer que au delà du fait que
tu as été complètement influencé par des
gens sur twitter qui est la poussait à
être à dire des trucs assez scandaleux
il ya aussi un effet buzz qui est que
pour seul objectif que l'on a qu il n'y
aa typiquement sur twitter c'est de se
taire ou chuter et de se faire larguer
eh bien il ya une façon qui marche
beaucoup mieux que les autres c'est dire
des trucs absolument scandaleux et
d'ailleurs ça contraste avec d'autres
comptes twitter qui sont également gérés
par des bottes mais qui vont partager
par exemple des images de pavage d'un
plan hyperbolique ça ça fait un petit
peu moins le buzz et ça fait un peu
moins la une des gros médias de façon
plus générale il semble vraiment et j'en
ai déjà parlé dans une vidéo lorsque
j'ai parlé de démocratie que à travers
ces réseaux sociaux notamment il ya
vraiment un système de surenchère c'est
à kidira le truc le plus scandaleux
parce que ce personnel sera le plus
réputé le plus cliqué et du coup il ya
un peu une surenchère à avoir des
phrases chocs l'époque qui tapent tout
ça parce que finalement nous humains
réagissant de façon pas si différente
finalement d'unia sur twitter on a
tendance à avoir une petite récompense à
chaque fois que l'on fait une suite qui
est très laïque est très partagée dans
savoir un petite montée d'adrénaline et
voir une petite gorgée de dopamine
lorsque on a ce genre de notification et
du coup on est poussé à des trucs de
plus en plus choc
et ça c'est en fait assez problématique
si on y réfléchit
puisque ça pousse toujours à tes phrases
plus en plus clash à chaque fois et dès
qu'on parle notamment d'un sujet comme
le sexisme le racisme va une tendance
vraiment au clash à avoir des phrases
chocs qui me semble extrêmement malsain
parce qu'en fait ce sont des preuves d'
incroyablement difficile un peu
incroyablement subtil et incroyablement
compliqué est typiquement dans les
commentaires de la vidéo précédente il
ya pas mal de commentaires où c'est
difficile de savoir si la personne qui
écrit ses commentaires écrits au premier
ou au second degré est ce qu'elle est
juste en train de troller ou à ce
qu'elle dit vraiment ce qu'elle pense
ou est ce qu'elle sait juste parfois mal
exprimé ça peut arriver aussi bref
j'aurais tendance à vous encourager sur
ces sujets assez sensible de ne pas
chercher à trop trop laid ou si vous
vous êtes en train de troller fait en
sorte qu'elle soit vraiment clair que
vous soyez en train de troller parce
qu'après ça empêche de d'avoir une
discussion intelligente sur ces
problèmes qui sont encore une fois né ce
qu'ils nécessitent vraiment beaucoup
d'intelligence parce que ce sont des
problèmes extrêmement compliqué à
résoudre fait par exemple comme géo qui
précise dans sa question que en fait y'a
pas de trop dans sa négation et que
c'est une vraie question qui se pose à
savoir la question qui se pose de savoir
si une machine qui ne ferait qu
interpréter les données supposant
qu'elles le fassent correctement
est ce que finalement cette machine peut
vraiment être considéré racistes alors
ce qui arrive souvent c'est qu'il ya des
billets dans les données dans le sens où
la manière dont on a collecté les
données à cause notamment du paradise
aux simpson fait qu'il ya des facteurs
de confusion donc typiquement le
résultat est le cas des résultats des
recherches sur google images on voit
beaucoup plus car ce qu'on tape le mot
pdg beaucoup plus d'hommes que de femmes
ça ça vient aussi du fait que l'image la
plus pertinente d'une certaine manière
d'un pdg
si on prend l'image la plus pertinente
pas c'est sûr c'est peut-être celle d'un
homme parce qu'on a fait il ya plus
d'hommes pdg que de femmes
mais comme google image va vouloir
montrer uniquement des images qui sont
vraiment les plus pertinentes
si on prend à chaque fois juste l'image
la plus pertinente sur chaque site
on n'obtient que des images d'hommes on
obtient alors une collection d'image et
c'est cette collection d'image qui n'est
pas représentative de la proportion
hommes femmes est en fait en pratique
tout cas c'est ce que disait le docteur
elisa sévissent dans une vidéo sur ses
tablettes
en fait la proportion d'hommes et femmes
et pas du tout celle que l'on retrouve
lorsqu'on fait des requêtes sur google
images
nous voyons qu'il ya ce genre de biais
qui est dû à des biais de sélection
typiquement sûr qu'il faut corriger si
on veut avoir une bonne représentation
de ce qu'est un pdg et surtout de à qui
il faut proposer un job de pdg puisque
après il faut imaginer que va
ce genre d'image le résultat de rickett
est utilisé par des sites de
recommandations de jobs qui vont par
exemple prendre une offre de jobs et du
coup l'a proposé à différentes personnes
et sylvia qui fait ça a construit son
raisonnement à partir des résultats des
requêtes sur google images elle pourrait
se dire que du coup les personnes les
plus susceptibles d'être intéressés par
ce globe serait les sommes qui
pourraient du coup y avoir des erreurs
de raisonnement qui sont en fait
absolument non preview une certaine
manière ne pas avoir une compréhension
plus fondamental du monde peut conduire
à ce genre de raccourcis on a déjà
longuement parlé notamment dans la vidéo
sur le paradoxe simpson et les facteurs
de confusion
ceci étant dit comme de préciser aussi
vidéo sur dirty oil et il serait aussi
scientifiquement erronées que de penser
qu'il n'ya aucune différence entre les
blancs les noirs et aucune différence
entre les hommes et les femmes qui
seraient aussi erronée d'un point de vue
scientifique d'avoir une vision
totalement égalitaire des choses il ya
des spécificités c'est bien de les
apprendre qu intéressant de voir c'est
que ces différences entre différents
groupes sociaux ne sont pas forcément
génétique c'est aussi souvent des
différences culturelles ou d'origine
socio-économique typiquement les taux
d'intérêt pour les noirs vont être plus
élevé que pour les blancs souvent parce
que le taux de remboursement des prêts
paris noir est souvent plus faibles que
pour les blancs pour une raison assez
simple c'est que souvent les noirs sont
plus pauvres que les bons aux états unis
et ça ça vient encore une fois pas de
raisons génétiques mais deux raisons
tout simplement historique puisque m'ont
offert un cours d'histoire des états
unis mais bon historiquement eu
d'énormes inégalités socio-économiques
entre les blancs et les noirs et du coup
il ya différents ce qui va se servait
encore aujourd'hui dans les taux de
remboursement des blancs et des noirs et
du coup niveau des prêts bancaires
tirent en effet avoir une différence
entre les plans les noirs qui est
prévisible
d'un point de vue totalement historique
et là il ya plusieurs façons d'aborder
la question du racisme
c est ce qu on essaie du coup sachant
qu'il ya ce biais historique on essaie
de rétablir ce biais du coup alors
correspondre à rétablir l'égalité entre
deux groupes sociaux que parfois on
parle
debiais deux groupes pour diminuer les
biens de groupe il faut nécessairement
augmenter les billets individuels
typiquement dans ce cas cela reviendrait
à dire qui va falloir faire de
discrimination positive typiquement pour
les noirs ce qui veut dire que à dossier
égale un blanc et un noir ne seraient
pas traités de la même façon dont
l'émission du billet entre les groupes
se ferait au détriment du billet
individuel
donc c'est un grand débat notamment
entre sociologues de savoir comment
gérer ces deux types de biais alors j'ai
eu l'occasion d'assister à des
séminaires souvent donnés par des
informaticiens est vrai que les parades
manière intuitive les informaticiens ont
tendance à penser que ce qui compte
c'est les billets sont les biens
individuels pas légué deux groupes
mais souvent les sociologues affirme que
en faites pas pour des raisons notamment
peut-être utilise le plus global
si on arrive à rétablir plus d'égalité
entre des grands groupes sociaux comme
par exemple entre les blancs et les
noirs
ça pourra permettre de résoudre plein
d'autres problèmes à la fois donc il
faut avoir une vision un peu globale de
la société quand on pense à ces
questions et c'est extrêmement difficile
prétendre est absolument pas pouvoir
vous donner un avis qui soit pertinent
quand même moi ce que j'aimerais
vraiment voir disons dans les
commentaires c'est plus des
questionnements que des réponses
intuitif que vous avez parce que la
morale intuitive et souvent très
mauvaise pour penser ce genre de
questions elle espère que j'avais cette
vidéo alors ce sont les sujets
extrêmement tôt tu as qui éveille big n
on nous donc essayer d'être conscient de
la ligue à nîmes en vo moment
vous montrer cette vidéo et c'est vous
dire à ce que j'écris ça par config à
nice mme ou est-ce que j'ai vraiment
bien réfléchi à cette question où est ce
qu'on va essayer d'écrire plus des
questionnements que des réponses parce
que c'est vraiment des questions
difficiles et généralement on n'y a pas
assez réfléchi et ce qui est intéressant
de voir c'est que en fait utilisé les ja
permet non seulement de soulever les
questions mais peut-être pour permettre
aussi de résoudre certaines de ces
questions mieux que si c'était des
humains qui était en charge avec moi ces
questions c'est quelque chose dont on va
continuer à parler dans cette dans les
prochains épisodes
notamment on va voir des apports
bénéfiques plaisir pour les sociétés qui
sont assez clairement bénéfique on va
dire notamment la prochaine fois on va
parler de liens et de la santé notamment
avec les ja sauve des vies
si vous avez aimé cet épisode de penser
à le lac et à l'eau commenté à partir de
quand ça vous abonner pour les futurs
d'épisodes merci au tibet cordon et
j'espère que mr est là la prochaine fois
mais comme indique la philosophe
américaine elizabeth anderson bien loin
d'opérer une harmonie entre capitalisme
libéral d'un côté et socialisme
interventionniste d'un autre le loc
egalitarian et homme produit des effets
pervers non désirable qui ne peuvent au
final que trahir son ambition égalitaire
une société égalitariste des chances
pourrait en effet produire des jugements
moraux humiliant de la part de l'état et
hiérarchisé tous les individus en
capable et incapable en effet pour
pouvoir compenser les déficits provoqués
par le hasard
il faut bien que l'état vérifie si les
capacités et les incapacités des
individus peuvent lui être imputée ou
non une telle vérification demanderait
la mise en place d'une administration
quasi inquisitrice et moralisante qui
devrait passer son temps à scruter la
vie des individus et tous leurs
antécédents la voie à privilégier c'est
celle du test and learn
c'est une approche qui a été a mis en
place par toujours discovery en afrique
du sud
et l'idée là aussi a été de lier un
tracker fitness avec une assurance santé
mais avec un programme de fidélité plus
vous marchez plus vous cumulez des
points
plus vous avez des coupons de réductions
dans les magasins bio dans des magasins
de sport